uh congratulations on the launch of
hay.com i got on it very quickly
unfortunately um jason hey.com was taken
by some squatter
yeah that guy's a bastard i'm never
gonna get my jason on there
i'll sell to tell me the background of
why you felt
in the year 2020 or i think maybe you
started working on this in 2019 actually
why you felt in 2019 would be a good
idea
to start an email competitor or a new
email
right so we actually started a couple
years ago but you know here's the thing
like
the last time okay let me step back
we're an email all day long
most people are no matter what else you
use you're also probably an email too
and the last time email was exciting was
16 years ago when gmail launched in 2004
you probably remember that i remember
yeah waiting for invites getting trying
to get
you know 16 years man it's been 16 years
and so you know we just
we have this thing where we just get
really easily frustrated by like bad
by things that haven't improved for a
long time yeah and that's what kind of
why we built base camp back in 2004 is
because project management hadn't
improved for a long time and so
we spent our time in email as well so we
said like let's
let's worry about this can we do
something better now originally though
it started out as a cr we were
experimenting with um
improving high-rise which is our crm
tool yeah we're going to make a whole
new version of hirise
but as we got into it we started making
all these email specific features and
we're like you know what
we can we want this for all of our email
not just business email but personal
email i want to manage email this way so
we started going deeper into email and
started to really pay attention to all
the work arounds because the email is
one workaround after another like for
example you need to get back to someone
what do you do well you mark the email
unread
that's not that's a total hack it's like
a total worker it's a complaint but
that's what everyone does right yeah
and so we just kind of started piling up
these these annoying frustrations with
these workarounds that we all have to go
through every single day and we've just
sort of
given in and put up with them and we're
like that shouldn't be that way anymore
so uh we started digging in and and said
you know a lot of people use email it's
everyone likes to think it's dead it's
not anywhere near dead it's very vibrant
very alive
it's the only real sort of widest common
denominator communication medium that
works no matter where you are no matter
what provider you use
and it's a wonderful thing and we want
to breathe new life into it
and the basic protocol of email has
not changed all that much it really is
interesting
how open source you know
platforms whether it's the web or email
seem to be the most resistant
um to corporate ownership or closing
obviously podcasting being the other one
that has long been open with rss feeds
and attachments although maybe that's at
risk now
um because of uh certain players wanting
to have exclusives
how did you get the i'm wondering if the
under did you consider taking the
underlying protocol of
email and changing that in some way and
maybe you could educate us on that
underlying protocol who sets the
standards
for how email changes over time yeah
well
first off at a slightly higher level
when we attack this problem we decided
we're not going to build a
client we're not going to build
something that lives on top of gmail
right
for example or outlook or whatever
because you can't really innovate
when you're on top of someone else's
platform like that there's so many
things that are just fixed in place and
there's so much
legacy in email that you just can't
really improve that much around the
margins which is why most
email clients have been focused on
perhaps speed
or interface design or like some stuff
but you really can't
get too deep with improvements and so
with hey hey it's actually an email
service
it's not something that lives on top of
gmail it's a service we're an email
provider
right so when you sign up for hey
hey.com you get an hey.com email address
and because we can sort of control that
we're vertically integrated essentially
we make the clients and we make the
service we can do all sorts of things
that just clients can't do now
the thing though is with email of course
is that it has to be interoperable so
you have to make sure that you know if
we send an email out of hey it can be
reached you know someone in gmail can
get it someone from gmail can email us
so
we have to follow those basic standards
as far as who defines those i don't even
know
yeah but but we know what they are like
that's the beauty of email of course
which is different than let's say
sms in some countries like even sending
an sms doesn't work
yeah that's why you need twilio to kind
of be your ambassador
to just resolve all of those issues
which are super complicated
which is what's so great about email is
that email doesn't have those things so
we had to of course make it work with
that at that level but everything else
we could redo and reinvent and and
and reintroduce in new ways the way you
organize email the way
the control you have over who can email
you all these things we can do
because we're vertically integrated all
the way down to the bottom so that was
key for us how do